So how are we going to do this?
Are People just going to ask?
All right,
yes.
Speed brings chaos.
So you would ask that.
The question is,
the question is speech brings order out
of chaos.
That's what I said,
but it appears that speech brings chaos
out of order as well.
And the answer to that is it does,
right?
There was only so many complications I
could address in the talk
simultaneously.
If you look at,
if you look at the most archaic of
Archetypal Heroes,
the heroes confront something that
represents chaos.
It's usually a monster that bears a
treasure of some sort,
and that's a symbolic representation of
the class of all unexplored things,
right?
Because things that we have not yet
explored are threatening and
destructive,
but also offer us infinite potential,
but more elaborated hero stories,
let's say.
Also reverse that and say that,
well,
there are times when the order has
become so corrupted,
rigid,
that free speech fragments that into its
parts so that it can rejuvenate itself.
And so actually in the gospels,
that's the hero.
That Christ is basically represented as.
He's not so much the dragon.
Confronting the dragon slayer who
gathers the treasure,
although that's implicit in the in the
juxtaposition of Christ with the figure
of like a Serpentine Satan,
but Christ is the thing that stands up
against the corrupt state and
rejuvenated through speech and so
technically speaking,
free speech.
The logos is the thing that mediates
between chaos and order and you can
think about this is represented in,
in,
in many cultures.
This idea,
you can see it most specifically,
I would say in the Dallas
conceptualization because in the Dallas
world being is made out of chaos and
order,
Yin and Yang,
masculine and feminine.
Fundamentally it's chaos in order in
order is the fact that wherever you go,
there are things you understand in order
and chaos is the fact that wherever you
go there are things you don't understand
and so the idea is that being is made
out of the things that you understand
and the things that you don't understand
and it's always that way,
which is why dow is the symbol of being
per se,
and it's the case.
Your brain is adapted.
In fact,
it's partly why it has two hemispheres
for the world that you understand and
the world you don't understand the world
you understand roughly speaking,
being handled by the left and the world.
You don't understand roughly speaking,
being handled by the right.
Well,
it's that line down the middle,
that's Dow,
that's meaning,
and if you have one foot in chaos and
one foot in order,
you're maximizing information,
float and rejuvenating yourself at the
same time that you're maintaining
structure and you will report on that
internally as engagement in the world.
It's the most fundamental orienting
sense that you have and it's deeply
instantiated neurologically,
unbelievably deeply,
and so it really is the case from an
evolutionary perspective that reality is
chaos and order.
It's that to which you're adapted and so
sometimes you're speaking on behalf of
chaos and sometimes you're speaking on
behalf of order.
It's more complicated than now too
though,
because when we have a dialog saying
we're,
we're mutually attempting to climb
towards the truth.
Instead of convincing each other that
we're right,
say,
then what we're doing is engaging in the
simultaneous fragmentation of old and
archaic belief systems and they're
updating and you can experience that
because someone will say something that
sets you back and then you'll get what
they're saying and it'll click together
and what you're experiencing is the
death of a of a,
of an old conceptualization structure,
its disintegration,
and then it's reconfiguration in a
tighter and tighter order and people
love that.
They live for that.
It's,
it's,
it's really,
it's what keeps you alive and you can
experience that in a deep conversation,
a truthful conversation,
a meeting of the minds and soul,
and people love that.
It's curative.
All psychotherapists know this because
what you do in psychotherapy as well,
in addition to helping people face the
things that they're most afraid of so
that they can overcome them,
is to allow them to tell someone the
truth.
What happened to you all?
Listen,
so they tell you and they take
themselves apart and put themselves
together.
Well,
they're speaking the truth about what
happened and it puts them together.
It's at the.
No,
the two fundamental elements of
psychotherapy are let's find what you're
afraid of and avoiding and help you
confront it so that you can gather the
information that's there and let's allow
you to lay your story out in all of its
catastrophe in detail so that you can
straighten yourself out through speech.
It's exactly what happens in
psychotherapy,
so when it should happen in every real
relationship,
it's.
It's the spiritual purpose of a marriage
fundamentally,
right?
Because you face someone who's different
than you that you are tied to and cannot
run from,
and so you can reveal your really,
really,
it's a critical.
It's a critical part of marriage because
if you can run from someone,
they will never show you their true face
because if someone shows you their true
face,
you will run,
and so you say,
in a marriage ceremony,
I will allow you to show me your true
face and I will not run,
and unless you mean that you'll never be
married.
You'll never understand what it means
and you'll never reap the benefits of
it.
Which are practical obviously,
but also spiritual and psychological.
There's a reason for the vow,
but it has to be a vow because otherwise
you have a back door open and you'll
never really tell the person what your
light and no bloody wonder because
really,
who wants to know what you're like,
not even you.
That's for sure.
I'm not surprised.
I want to thank you because what was
surprising about your lecture today was
this concept of altruism.
I think you've been able to just put
everything together and at the end come
up with a higher value of altruism and
to was a surprise.
You don't come in here and I have a
relationship with altruism and the one
that I find that it's difficult for me
is that this is an evolutionary process.
So my brain is an organ is developed.
You know,
and and I'm amazed at how often I think
of three people,
me,
myself,
and I do the point where where I've
actually written down,
counted all of the iterations of me,
myself and I and neither my thoughts or
my speech or even in someone else's.
Then you'll get the page.
We think of.
We,
as far as I've been able to ascertain,
it's because I have to expend energy to
think about someone else and and and yet
yet I'm addicted to decent comfort
because my natural evolution is what?
Peace and comfort.
You hear it in alcoholics anonymous.
Take the problem.
You're addicted to ease and comfort.
How do I overcome my,
my sense of ease and comfort to be able
to make altruism
a more natural state of being.
Good.
Good question.
So the question is,
the first was a comment about the
emphasis in my talk today on altruism,
and the second is how do I,
how do people overcome their proclivity
to only act on their own behalf?
Okay,
so the first thing I will say is that I
don't believe that what I spoke about
today was in favor of altruism.
And,
and that's not a negative comment on
your question,
but there.
So there's a,
there's,
there's a pride.
Here's a primary religious injunction.
Treat the other person like you would
like to be treated yourself.
That does not mean be nice to other
people.
It does not mean sacrifice yourself
excessively for other people.
It means think about the other person as
if they were you,
and figuring out how you can mutually
interacts to better both of you.
At the same time,
you have to build yourself into the
equation.
It's an equation.
It's not that it's not that others are
more valuable,
it's that we're all valuable,
were equally valuable,
and then you think,
well,
how do you remind yourself of that?
And the answer to that is through terror
because terror is the genuine motivator,
so they save.
Fear of God is the beginning of all
wisdom.
What does that mean?
On means?
First that you don't get away with
anything and it's really useful to know
that because if you really know that you
won't to get away with while you still
will because people are stupid but,
but at least it will mitigate the
possibility.
So
here,
I'll tell you something that young said.
This is quite.
This is quite profound and I think the
right answer to this question.
So young believed he was interested in
the emergence of higher morality.
Something that the developmental
psychologist,
Yom Piaget was also interested in.
Here's a thought.
We started out as individuals,
then we learned to play games with other
people,
kids,
children,
learn how to play games with other
and that made them social.
So our society is a game.
It's a giant gate that we're all playing
together voluntarily.
And so children will first learned how
to play the game and only later did they
learn the rules of the game and he
learned how to play the game first and
then learn the rules,
how to speak the rules,
and then at some point they realized
that they were also creators of the
rules.
And so that's moral development on a
continual on,
on a.
it's not a continuum,
it's fractured staircase upward,
but young was interested in elements of
moral action that were higher than that.
And so he conceptualized it
symbolically.
So imagine this,
you did this in the last book he wrote
called mysterium conjunction us.
So imagine that you exist so that your
conceptual structures and your emotions
are in an uneasy relationship with one
another.
So you're sort of a house divided
amongst yourself.
And so what you have to do is you have
to put together your mind and your and
your emotions so that they're working as
a,
as a unit,
and you do that in part by actually
being forthright about what it is that
you want for yourself and to other
people and to learn how to negotiate
that so that inner tension disappears.
And so now you're a unified.
You're a unified entity of emotion and
thought they're not conflicting with one
another.
And then what you do is you take that
entity which is still in some sense,
separate from your body because you're
not acting these out and you bring those
two together and he thought about that
as the psychological equivalent of the
incarnation had integrated spirit
integrating with the body.
And what that means is that you take
your emotions and motivations and
capacity for thinking that are now one
thing and you act out those things you.
So you embodied them in the world.
And that's another thing that brings
integrity.
And then there was a step past that in
the step past that is to understand that
there's no d.
So you have the integrated spirit,
mind and body
in opposition to the world and this,
the next thing you do is realize that
there is no opposition with the world.
Is that what you are is a.
This is very,
very complicated.
You're walking down the street,
but the street is a good example of this
in Toronto and they're guesstimated
alcoholic,
schizophrenia,
littering the landscape so to speak.
You walk around them,
you say,
well,
that's not me.
It's like,
yes it is.
It's you in so far as your tendency is
to react in a negative way and to start
the territory.
It's a disturbance in your field of
being.
It's you.
Now you don't know what to do about it
and I wouldn't recommend that you do
anything because you'd probably just
make it worse.
It's a very big problem that's lying
there on the sidewalk and it may be well
beyond your capacity to fix it,
but in so far as it's a disturbance in
your field of being,
it's you,
it's you and all the problems that are
in the world that you experience there,
you and so you stop thinking about
things in terms of an opposition between
what's good for you and what's good for
the world because there is no
difference.
There's no difference between the two
and that that doesn't mean that the
pathway from what's good for you in your
more limited domain to what's good for
everyone is an easy one to compute.
It's very,
very difficult.
But there is no,
there is no technical difference between
them,
you know,
so if I'm engaged in a psychotherapeutic
dialogue with my clients when I'm doing
it properly,
it's not like they're learning from me.
It's that we're learning together and
every time I solved one of their
problems or help them solve one of their
problems are you help myself.
So of one of my problems,
you know,
because people bring to me,
bring into my sessions the terrible
things that go wrong with people in
life.
Their partner has cancer,
their father's father has Alzheimer's,
they're suffering with alcoholism.
Their career is collapsing like these
aren't things that are happening to
them.
These are things that happen to everyone
and to figure out how to solve that for
someone is to figure out how to solve it
for yourself.
There's no difference whatsoever and so
and then so there's to know that to,
to think of that and certainly works in
in a,
in an intimate relationship.
If you think that you're somehow
different than your wife,
while certainly she's going to remind
you otherwise constantly,
but it's an.
It's an error.
It's an error because you're.
You're tied together so tightly that
whatever happens to one inevitably
happens to the other and that's true in
in the work reality that we all inhabit.
So then the terror thing emerges.
When you start to realize that those
problems that you don't address that or
maybe magnified by your impulsive and
foolishly self centered and instrumental
behavior,
you're manipulating the world on behalf
of your own narrow interests,
those will come back to haunt you and so
it's a terrifying thing to think
through,
but once you think through and
understand it,
then what happens is you're more afraid
of acting selfishly,
then you are willing to do it.
You think,
no,
I'm not doing that.
Why?
Because I know all hell will break loose
if I do that and I'm not going there.
And so the terror element is a huge one.
It makes it,
it,
it fortifies your because you can't just
act
properly.
You don't have the moral fortitude for
that.
You can aim it the good and run from
what's terrible.
Then you're,
then you're motivated.
So if I've understood you,
I just want to recap,
if you're suggesting a subsidiary with
your environment,
not the,
not the few,
uh,
reaching out to your environment.
That's an expenditure of energy,
but rather as an investment.
Yes,
it's an investment.
That's a very good way of putting it.
Yes.
I was wondering if you could,
if it's plausible,
it's race on our market.
Typical or narrative origin for some of
the intellectual
denied the structures of language as
corresponds to reality.
Denied the psyche of the individual.
I think you've done some of your top two
that you think is possible from a
psychological perspective to trace the
narrative,
origin,
postmodernism and human behavior,
or is it so unnatural?
No,
no,
no.
It's an architect,
architect.
I mean there's always.
There's always a forest,
so to speak,
that opposes.
The logo's always had that.
That's the hostile brothers.
It's a classic archetypal story.
There's always cain and Abel.
There's always hostility between the two
primary modes of operating in the world,
so and this is the.
This is the modern manifestation of that
and it's partly.
It's partly a good thing.
Maybe in some sense because it's useful
to be deeply challenged.
It's good to have an enemy because the
enemy makes you think.
The enemy tells you things that no one
else will tell you.
It's a DNA and it's an advert.
Adversity.
It's an ad.
It's the adversary that,
that,
that stops you from being merely inert,
and so postmodernism plays that role.
It's,
it's extraordinarily critical,
but,
but things can go too far and and,
and the motives and things can go too
far when they go too far,
they reverse.
That's what happens and hopefully
they're reversing now hopefully
as being mainly associated,
we seem to be seeing something that had
a different form today that might be,
is more associated with the family.
Can you speak to that and also what is
the nature of this power over men that
it seems to be able to silence us.
Okay,
so the question is,
the totalitarian forms that we've seen
primarily in the past have been male
and,
but maybe we're seeing something
different now.
I really don't think it's different.
I think it's,
it's of the other common kind that's
expanded in its dominion,
so you imagine that there's an essential
feminine pathology just as there is an
essential masculine pathology and the
essential feminine pathology.
Freud mapped out it's the eternal mother
and the mother is the mother that gets
too close to her children.
Right.
And intermingles herself with them too,
too great.
A degree that in her attempts to protect
them undermines them fatally.
And so there's a classic representation
of the feminine in the West and the
classic representation is married and
here,
here's one of the representations.
It's lovely and it's derived at least in
part from the story of Mary and the
snake in the garden of Eden.
And so Mary has her foot on a serpent
and she's holding Christ off to the side
like this.
Well,
that's exactly what mothers have always
done.
It's a biological portrait of human
women is they hold their infants out of
the reach of the terrible Serpentine
Predator.
Obviously that's what we do.
Well that's fine,
but adults aren't infants and neither
are children.
And if you treat them like they are,
you undermine them,
you,
you pathologize them,
you turn them into old infants.
That's an ugly thing.
And that's the Friday a nightmare you
know,
in,
in this happens in therapy very
frequently.
I mean,
you can be tangled into a terrible
relationship with your father.
That's often either because he was
absent or abusive or tyrannical.
Something like that,
but that the standard pathology with mom
is she did everything for you.
Well,
what's left for you to do nothing
including never leaving.
Right,
and that's the motivation for the woman
who's nothing but protective mother.
There's no role outside of nurturing,
of nurturing,
nurturing,
of nurture,
and of infants,
of nurturer,
of infants.
Well,
you just keep them.
Infants,
they'll never leave.
It might kill you in your sleep,
but they'll never leave.
Sure,
sure.
I mean it's so comical watching the
feminist postmodernist in particular
rattle on about the absence of gender
reality and act out the archetipal
devouring mother at exactly the same
time for them,
for them.
The world is divided into predators and
infants and the predators are evil and
need to be stopped and the infants need
to be cared for.
Well,
that's what the mother does,
but adults are not infants
and all you do is destroy them when you
treat them that way,
especially when they're adolescents and
just starting to develop.
Now there's.
There's a rule that I attempted to abide
by when I had small children and the
rule was don't do anything for your
children that they can do themselves and
it's annoying that rule because it takes
you like 15 seconds to to dress a two
year old,
but you let the two year old dress
himself.
It's like 15 minutes or 20 minutes or
half an hour.
You chase them around the house,
but if you let them learn to dress
themselves,
then you don't have to dress themselves.
Any direct dress them anymore and they
can do it and you do that with setting
the table and you do that with
everything.
It's like,
no,
it's okay.
You do that now while I care for you so
much.
Let me do that for you.
It's like I don't care for you at all
when I say that I don't care for you at
all.
I'm going to stop doing everything I
possibly can for you as rapidly as I
possibly can say,
well,
that's great.
That's how you work in an old age home.
Do not do anything for the inhabitants
that they can do themselves because you
robbed them of the last vestiges of
their independence,
right?
It's what you do when you're a manager,
if you're a good manager,
you make yourself superfluous by
extending autonomy and independence to
the people that you manage so that they
can take over the whole job.
You don't do that by doing everything
for people and you certainly don't do
that by dividing the world
archetypically and uncritically into
predators.
Those who have more and victims,
infants,
those who have nothing and acting like
all you can ever do is protect them.
Protect.
First of all,
you can't protect people.
You can only make them strong.
That's it.
You cannot protect them.
You can make them strong and then they
can predict themselves,
but then they don't need you.
Right,
and there's the underground pathological
elements of the devouring mother.
It's like,
never leave me.
Here's the deal.
I'll do everything for you.
You just never leave,
right?
That's sleeping with your mother,
That's the Friday a nightmare,
right?
You don't invite your child into your
bed,
right?
You distinguished between them and you,
you distinguish between them and your
husband and you facilitate their
independence.
A part of the reason why it's useful to
have a mother and a father is because
the mother has to fall insanely in love
with the infant or she'd throw it out
the window,
right?
Because they're.
They're insanely demanding and they're
always right,
right?
Because the right way to treat an
infant,
especially before nine months is I'll do
everything for you and you're always
right in your needs.
Take priority over everyone's at one
else's and anybody that threatens you is
terrible.
Exactly right,
but after once the kid is ambulatory and
starting to be independent,
that's the wrong attitude.
The attitude then is no,
get the hell on with it,
and men who are less prone to negative
emotion and less compassionate are much
better at fostering that kind of
independence and so it's usually then
when they step into the family and start
playing with the kids rough and tumble
play and pushing them forward and
saying,
you know,
get on with it.
You can do it.
You can do it at home.
It's very hard for a mother to play both
those rules because she has to fall,
so in love with her infant that it's
difficult for her to be young,
universal caregiver and disciplinarian
at the same time,
you know,
because the roles are the roles run
contrary to one another.
So now women have entered the political
sphere right on moss and so they're
gonna bring their essential nature with
them all the while saying there's no
such thing as essential nature.
It's like,
yeah,
there is.
Can we grow by the state of Western
civilization using the new chain idea
that God is dead?
Well,
it's the wrong question in some sense
because I think it's too diffuse to me.
They issue Morris,
do you have problems in your life that
you're not addressing that you could
solve?
And the answer is yes,
and it's an easy thing to figure out.
You sit on your bed one morning and say,
okay,
there's some things that need to be done
that I don't want to do that I could do
that would make things better by the end
of the day.
What are they?
Well,
your,
your conscience will deliver those
soccer's no time flat now and then you
might have to say,
okay,
well how do I entice myself into doing a
few of those and if you ask,
instead of trying to force yourself to
do it like you're a tyrant and a slave
at the same time,
you can usually negotiate with yourself
so that you'll start to sort those
things out,
sort them out,
put your house in order and then move
out.
Move on and out.
Yes,
that's a 40 and slipped by the way.
So it's important because the thing is
you have a practice domain right there.
There are things that are within your
grasp that you couldn't fix.
Fix them and you'll learn.
You'll learn because it's harder than it
looks,
fixed them and you'll learn how to fix
things and then something else will
beckon as another problem that you could
fix.
You know you all have your problems.
What does that mean?
Like there's an infinite number of
problems in the world.
Some of them happened to be yours.
Why is that?
I don't know exactly,
but you have your problems.
Great.
Solve them.
You know,
one of the things I learned as a
therapist,
every therapist has to learn this is
because one of the things you wonder
when you're first starting to be a
clinician is how do you not take the
catastrophes of your client's home with
you?
And the answer to that is because it's
immoral to.
They're not your problems,
they're their problems like their,
their,
their life.
You all,
your problems are your life.
You don't want to solve someone else's
problems for them because you take away
the deep meaning.
That's to be found in having them work
through the problems on their own.
And then you steal the credit.
Well,
I can help you with that.
It's like,
well,
yeah,
maybe,
but I don't help you with the next
problem.
Then.
So in any case,
you sort sort out the problems that are
right in front of you and you will,
it will make you grow very,
very rapidly and then you'll be able to
sort out more complex problems without
making them worse.
So.
So you mentioned that through discussion
and dialogue,
we can order the chaos of the world
together.
But do you not think that there needs to
be a higher creator,
an essence of grace,
but it would be possible like how can we
each being flawed,
even working together
create meaning or something good?
We don't understand what we are.
We don't understand our own
consciousness.
It has a quality of some sort and it
meant it manifests itself within us.
It's an orientation towards the good.
That might be one way of thinking about
it,
freedom to do evil,
but an orientation towards the good and
so you participate in whatever that
transcendent element of you is while you
try to speak the truth and sort out the
world.
It serves as a guide.
So I know that you're making a,
a,
a query about some transcendent reality.
Maybe the transcendent reality of God,
but that's the best answer you're going
to get out of me.
Yes.
Okay.
Two questions.
What's my opinion on the alt right and
what's my opinion on cultural
appropriation?
The idea of cultural appropriation is
absolute nonsense.
That's that.
Thank you.
No,
there's no difference between cultural
appropriation and learning from one
another.
They're the same thing.
Now,
that doesn't mean I can't,
that doesn't mean that there's no theft
between people.
There is no,
and it doesn't mean that just because
you encounter someone else's ideas,
you have an immediate right to those
ideas as if they were your own.
But the idea that manifesting in your
own behavior,
some element of another culture,
the idea that that's somehow immoral is
insane.
It's actually one of the bases of peace.
You know,
one of the things that the various
groups of human beings that exist have
to offer each other is the tremendous
value of their culture.
You know,
it's been really interesting to me,
for example,
to watch the response of,
of all of everyone,
but for this argument to you,
for young Caucasian males to hip hop,
you know,
there's an aggressiveness about hip hop
that's really attractive to young
Caucasian males and there's something
absurd about,
about the,
the,
the spectacle of the young Caucasian
males taking on the persona of inner
city black gang members.
You know,
but,
but I'm sympathetic to it because
there's an aggressiveness to that,
to that art form that's a necessary
corrective to the insistence that the
highest moral virtue for a modern man is
harmlessness,
which is observed.
Women don't even like harmless man.
They hate them.
They liked that.
No.
What women
want are dangerous men who are civilized
and they want to help civilize them.
That's beauty and the beast.
So,
you know,
I'll tell you a funny story and only
engineers could have come up with this
because they are the only ones that have
the unparalleled blindness to social
convention that would allow them to
discover it.
So the Google engineers,
I like engineers by the way because
they're very straightforward.
The Google engineers wrote a book awhile
back called a billion wicked thoughts,
which was a study of Internet searches,
billions of them literally,
and they were looking a lot of
pornography use.
And while there's lots of known about
male pornography use,
partly and it's easy to understand.
I mean males are pretty visually
oriented in what attracts them to
pornography is fairly straightforward.
You can tell that if you look at
graffiti and a men's washroom,
you know it's like two circles and the
triangle and the men are absolutely
transfixed.
Bye
For women in the story is more complex.
They use pornography too,
but it tends to be literary because
women tend to like words more than they
like visual stimuli.
And so the Google guys tried to track
down the architectural structure of how
they didn't use those words of female
pornography use.
And so some of you know how many of you
know what a Harlequin romance is.
Okay,
good.
So those are archetypal stories,
right?
That's the taming of the wild man.
Essentially by the,
by the desirable in virgin a woman.
And if you think women don't want that,
then you better bloody well come up with
an explanation for 50 shades of grey.
Right?
Which is the most,
the most rapid selling novel in human
history and,
and merged at exactly the same time that
all of this noise about the lack of the
absence of gender roles is being
produced on Mohs.
It's like perfect female fantasy.
It's exactly archetypally correct.
It's beauty and the beast,
so what the dual guys showed was the
structure of beauty and the beast,
although they didn't use that as a
reference that the female pornographic
fantasy was wild guy,
you know,
somewhat careless about the wants and
desires of others attractive to
everyone.
Therefore,
high status,
tamed by the magic of a single woman and
brought into a relationship with her.
Okay,
so,
but here's the comical part.
This just made me laugh,
man.
It was like,
what were the five categories of most
desirable male entity used most broadly
and female pornography.
Oh,
it's so embarrassing.
Women,
you have to cover your head while I say
this because Vampire Werewolf,
billionaire,
surgeon and pirate.
All right.
Another question.
Yes.
A,
I hear a lot
what you're saying.
I want to drag you back to Yelp,
right?
Yes.
What the
we have right now and now the core is to
believe in ethnic nationalism,
but not the sort of oppositional
nationalism that we all know.
It's more of a rag salt or,
or do gyn universal nationalism.
Do you think this core belief of the alt
right is.
What is it logical?
Is it revenue?
Complete,
complete identification with the father
and that's necessary,
but the purpose of identification with
the father is to become the son,
right,
and I mean that in all of its symbolic
manifestation and the problem with
nationalism is that it forgets that it
forgets that the purpose of the nation
is to give rise to the individual.
And so,
and what's happened now because our
identities have become fragmented,
is that there's a call to re constitute
the father and that's.
And that's at the core of the alt right,
thinking.
Well that's the benevolent part of the
alt right.
I mean there's a downside.
There's a negative side to everything.
I mean,
one of the things that's quite
disturbing about the alt right is it's
pro click,
continual proclivity to degenerate into
anti Semitism.
And I see that in the comments,
for example,
on my videos continually.
So it's oversimplified and there's a,
there's a terror,
there's also no true recognition or not
sufficient recognition that the state is
also a pathological monster and the all
right should understand that because of
course that's what the left continually
claims,
right?
The state is a pathological monster.
Oh,
they're trying to produce.
Sorry,
this,
the left is trying to produce.
I got that wrong.
It's the basis of the alt right's
criticism of the left.
The old right says the left is trying
always trying to expand the dominion of
the state and the state is a
pathological monster.
Yet what we should do is become
nationalists.
So like,
sorry guys,
there's a bit of a paradox there.
And uh,
well,
so,
so that's basically what I would say
about that.
It's not surprising and,
and as long as the radical left keeps
pushing the way they keep pushing,
then all right is going to continue to
grow.
Although it's very also very difficult
to tell at now to what degree to how
large the movement is or how serious it
is or any of those things at the moment.
So,
so just to bring you back to cultural
appropriation,
is it possible that that plus about half
a dozen other similar things that
appeared in the last 10 years rather
than be kind of like an empty or or
ridiculous baseless philosophy are in
fact tactical tactical constructs by
postmodernist and in March there's think
tanks we evidence for that would be in
the fact that they are always
selectively
enforced in a way which is the most
destructive possible to our occurrences.
So,
so that's,
uh,
that,
that kind of opens the broader question
of,
of conspiratorial action among political
groups,
let's say.
So here's a way of thinking about it.
And I think this works.
So in any coherent philosophy,
there's an impetus to action.
That's partly what makes the philosophy
coherent.
And postmodernism is a coherent
philosophy.
It has an impetus to action.
Now it's very difficult to describe the
entire structure of postmodernism
because it's fuzzy at the edges.
It bleeds into other things.
But imagine that there's a,
there's a core of,
there's a core of central concerns.
Now imagine that most people who are
normally postmodernists only understand
fragments of that core concern,
and so if you take the typical
indoctrinated social justice warrior,
Third Year Women's studies student,
you might say,
well,
she's only 15 percent postmodernist and
85 percent still human,
so but if you get,
if you get 10 people like that together,
20 people like that together,
each,
there's enough of the postmodernist
doctrine that fills the room because
it's fragmented into different people
that you have a coherent spirit that
animates the group and it will act as if
it has the intelligence of the
philosophy and it will manifest itself
as if it's conspiratorial.
Now there are elements that are also
conspiratorial because people do things
consciously as well,
but you should always assume,
assume stupidity before you assume
organized malevolence.
Right?
Right.
It keeps you.
It keeps your thinking player because
it's like.
It's not like there's no such thing as
organized malevolence,
but it's rare and it requires a lot of
skill.
Whereas sort of distributed stupidity
that can act conspiratorially without
having to have a central agent.
And so look there first and then and
only with great evidence,
make the next set of presuppositions.
So
I first found out about you on which
uses it
for that
reason,
people feel like they can say anything,
something,
maybe something is lost because on
facebook when your reputation is tied to
all the opinions that you feel like you
might want to test out,
but on,
on a place where it's anonymous,
it's not,
it's dark and you have an international
appeal.
You have this,
uh,
if I started at Jordan Peterson spread
within five minutes,
I've got people from 10 different
countries or countries that aren't,
don't have English as their main
language are joining in and talking
about,
you know,
the man who yells out the emperor has no
clothes.
I know we talked about how archetypes
seems to manifest.
What are you at
that is actually not me,
it's my wife
because she knows what I am and you
know,
it's not,
it's not all that great,
but all things considered
architectural point of view,
what has manifested?
What are you in embodying?
That seems to.
I mean,
we don't need to see your real ugly
face,
Jesus,
right?
I told you the story at the beginning of
the lecture.
I've been trying to solve a problem and
I really done everything I can to try to
solve that problem and I've been talking
about what I learned and who I learned
it from for 30 years,
you know,
and that's had a positive impact as far
as I can tell them,
the people to whom I've taught it and so
I,
I'm someone who's tried to solve the
hardest problem that he could find.
That's,
that's all.
Thank you.
Do you think individuals today should
have a,
a viewed relationship with religion and
God to kind of rebuild the moral
authority that's been lost?
Absolutely.
Yeah.
I think the question was,
do I think that modern people should
have a renewed relationship with
religion and God?
It's like,
yes,
absolutely.
But it has to be predicated on,
on higher consciousness,
so to speak,
and I mean that.
I mean that very technically.
So this is what happened.
This is how our religious systems
developed.
I'll give you the very brief version.
So if you look at the structure of a
chimpanzee troop or a wolf pack,
there's an ethic and there has to be
because otherwise the wolves would tear
each other apart and so with the
chimpanzees.
So the chimpanzees in their,
in their dominance hierarchy structure
is learn how to act out a society just
like the wool stoop.
So here's a rule for a wolf.
Wolfej wants to be top dog and wolf be
wants to be top dog.
And so they,
they snarl at each other and they puff
out their funnel and they look big and
ferocious and they turned sideways to
scare each other.
And then one of them chickens out,
rolls over and shows his neck.
And basically that is the acting out of,
well,
I'm a useless applicant and you know,
your majesty can do what he will with
me.
And then the proper wolf king says,
yeah,
well I might need your useless carcass
to hold down a moose tomorrow so I
couldn't tear out your throat,
but I won't.
And then they both get up and go along
in the pack.
And so the reason I'm telling you that
is because there's an ethic there.
Here's another ethic among animals.
So if you,
if you take juvenile male rats,
they need to play,
they need to engage in rough and tumble
play or they develop attention deficit
disorder by the way,
which is quite interesting and something
to think about for your little rats in
school that are developing attention
deficit disorder.
So if you,
if you,
if you take a juvenile rat and he knows
he's going to be able to go into a space
where he can play,
he'll work to open a door to enter that
space.
So that's how you know he's motivated
because you can't ask them because you
can't speak rat and neither can he eat.
So you let go in the play space and
you'll add another rat go in there of
about the same age.
And imagine one rats 10 percent bigger
than the other.
So what happens first is the rats
wrestle.
It's not aggressive.
They wrestled just like worldwide
wrestling federation guys wrestle,
you know,
and,
and for many of the same reasons,
and the rats will pin each other and if
you pin the other rat you went.
So if you're 10 percent bigger than the
little rat,
then you can always pin them.
You can always win.
Okay.
So then what happens is the big rap
becomes dominant and the little rat
becomes subordinate.
They have a wrestling match and then
they part the next time they meet
because it's an iterated game,
the next time they meet the little ride
has to ask the big role to play.
And he does that the same way that you
ask a child to play,
you know,
you do your play stance just like a dog
does.
You can understand when a dog does that.
And so the little rat,
you know,
gets playful with the big rat and then
they play.
But if you pair them repeatedly,
the big grand house to let the little
rat win at least 30 percent of the time
or the little rat won't invite them to
play anymore.
It's right.
That's cool.
That's so cool.
Man.
Jack Yak,
Yak Panksepp discovered that he also
discovered that if you tickled rats,
they giggle,
but they do it ultrasonically,
so you have to.
You have to like that.
So he discovered the play circuit.
It's a major,
major neuroscience discovery,
and so there's an emergent ethic.
Can play a fair play ethic.
And now hale,
I can't remember what your question was.
Oh yes.
Okay.
So,
so,
so what happens is,
is that that there is an ethic that
emerges out of social interaction,
but then because human beings are
conscious,
we watched that ethic emerge and then we
start telling stories about it.
We tell stories about the honorable
person and the honorable person who
doesn't just win today's game,
but when's it in a way that makes
everyone invite them to play games
infinitely into the future.
Right?
So that makes you the Metta player.
That's what you're trying to be your
all.
And that's the hero who goes into the
unknown,
right?
It's the person who acts in proper
interactions with other people.
It's,
it's truly an emergent.
It's an emergent ethic.
It's real.
It's more real than anything else.
We map that and that's somehow
associated with our consciousness,
well,
we need to understand these sorts of
things in order to put a biological
structure underneath our religious
thinking again and to tie it into our
scientific knowledge and to become awake
and aware of these sorts of things so
that we can reestablish the foundation
underneath our culture and it's a
terrifying thing to do because it does
place a burden on people.
Right,
but you want to burden you and it's so
interesting.
It's really one of the things that's so
cool about what's been happening.
I don't understand this.
I commented on this at the University of
Toronto debate.
The first thing I did which was
unexpected to me and everyone else.
They didn't know what the Hell I was
doing.
As I said,
I looked around,
I said,
hey,
you know,
80 percent of the people in this room
are men.
It's like,
why is that something's going on here
and it's an indication that men and
women have different interests.
Ninety one percent of my viewers of man,
what the hell?
Why is that?
Look at this room.
It's almost all men and men don't come
to these sorts of things generally
speaking,
right?
Maybe because they're stubborn and
ornery,
but,
but so there's also something
specifically in this for men and,
and by,
by,
by implication for women because what do
you want?
Useless man.
No,
you don't want useless man,
that's for sure.
Although if you have a useless man,
you get to dominate him.
And so maybe that's not such a big price
to pay for having someone around that
you can treat like an infant.
So that's the downside of the,
of the war between men and women,
but a woman with any sense once a man
who's dangerous but team.
So maybe that's part of.
Well we'll leave it
that
characterize your classroom
occupying this space of the cognitive,
a general he will say,
I just want to know if you can
substantiate the fact that there is a
extraordinary diverse range of
disciplines which required different
kinds of skills,
uh,
in the university.
Also with the kind of confounding
variable that the university has made
may not be considered by some people to
be the most exclusively.
The exclusion was once was as a as a
representation of the enlightened.
Okay.
Well I can talk.
Let me talk about the situation at the
Ivy League universities.
First,
the question broadly speaking covers the
other question about intelligence and
about its diverse manifestations and
about its role in selection for
universities to go back and look at the
records at Harvard for example,
in the early 19 sixties,
the typical icu at for a Harvard student
was about 100,
five to 110,
not much above average,
but that's because they were finishing
schools for the,
for the rich,
roughly speaking,
and you know your.
If you had a rich father and he made his
money,
he was probably well above average in
intelligence,
but if you are his offspring,
there's regression towards the mean.
So there's no reason to assume that by
nature of your position you are going to
be particularly intelligent anyways.
The average Ivy League student wasn't,
was bright but not outstanding.
So now it's like 100 Iq,
145,
three standard deviations above the mean
because.
And the reason for that is because
they're selected by the sat scholastic
aptitude test.
It's an Iq test.
They won't say it's an Iq test,
but that doesn't matter.
It isn't tech,
it's an Iq test.
It's a simple as that.
Any any task that contains a
sufficiently diverse range of problem
solving questions that's rank ordered
in,
in accuracy among people is an Iq test.
The correlations like point eight,
five.
So and what has happened,
there's two things that have happened.
I mean the Ivy Leagues have got more and
more selective because they can and so
the average Iq of their students is just
continued to move upwards and then the
average Iq of the population is actually
increased to a substantive degree to
over the last 50 years.
Partly because partly perhaps mostly
because of improved nutrition and and
information exposure along among the.
Like the more deprived members of the
culture.
It's better to watch tv than to sit
alone in your crib for example,
and isolated and people have enough food
now.
So the really low end of the
intelligence spectrum is being
truncated.
And the general population Iq is
increased.
So with regards to institutions like the
University of Toronto,
say they average Iq at the University of
Toronto was somewhere between 120 130
and we know that because we've tested it
and it's not surprising because you're
basically selected for cognitive
prowess,
right?
Because grades are rough marker of
intelligence.
Conscientiousness,
by the way also matters independent
trade because the best two predictors of
university grades are conscientiousness
and intelligence,
not creativity by the way.
Zero correlation with creativity.
So yes.
Comments on this free.
How is committing suicide?
Why is that happening?
Guilt,
yes.
What you want?
Yeah.
There's lots for people to be guilty
about.
You know,
I mean you might say,
to what degree should you bear the
horrendous guilt of your ancestors?
And that's a.
that's a really hard question.
I mean,
the radical left answer would be to the
degree that you're privileged by your
ancestry,
you should bear their guilt.
Well,
Robo,
yes.
The question is then what you do?
Well,
what you should do is,
what I suggested today,
I would say is take responsibility for
your lives and understand that what you
have came at a terrible cost and that
you have an ethical obligation to use it
properly and that would be sufficient to
pay for the sins of your ancestors,
so to speak.
I think it's absolutely reprehensible
that the radical left dares to attribute
to to ethnically identified groups,
collective guilt.
There's absolutely no excuse for that.
It's completely murderous and that
should be rejected out of hand.
So,
but that's independent of the issue
about what you should do given that part
of your wealth is a consequence of
historical catastrophe.
So you should try to sort that out
roughly speaking and for everyone's
benefit,
but not necessarily because you're any
more guilty personally.
You're guilty as hell personally,
but so is everyone else.
That's the critical thing.
So is everyone else okay?
I would.
I would like to answer that question,
but I can't.
And the reason,
there's two reasons for that.
One is that it's,
there's,
there's a large element of the answer
that has to be legal and I can't do
that,
and the other part of it is because I've
actually too tired to formulate a
coherent response to that and I don't
want it formulated incoherent response.
So I'm sorry that I can't be.
I mean obviously I believe that people's
right to communicate should be as
untrammeled as possible,
but to bridge the gap between that and
your specific concern requires a feat of
mental energy that I can't do at the
moment and maybe maybe ever that at the
back.
The
social construct of a safe space that
our view on this whole white privilege
thing.
Is that university,
all these other universities?
No,
I think the idea of white privilege is
absolutely reprehensible and it's not
because white people aren't.
You know,
we have all sorts of privileges and most
people have privileges of all sorts and
you should be grateful for your
privileges and work to deserve them,
I would say.
But the idea that you can target an
ethnic group with a collective crime,
regardless of the specific innocence or
guilt of the constituent elements of
that group,
there is absolutely nothing that's more
racist than that.
It's absolutely a boring.
I can't
thank you.
If you,
if you really want to know more about
that sort of thing,
you should read about the Kulaks in the,
in the Soviet Union in the 19 twenties,
k,
u l a,
s because they were.
They were farmers who were very
productive.
They were the most productive element of
the agricultural strata in,
in Russia.
And they were virtually all killed or
raped and robbed by the collectivists
who insisted that because they showed
signs of wealth,
they were criminals.
And,
and,
and Roberts.
So.
And one of the consequences of the
prosecution of the Kulaks was the death
of 6 million Ukrainians from a famine in
the 19 thirties.
The idea of collectively held guilt at
the level of the individual as a legal
or philosophical principle is dangerous.
It's precisely this sort of danger that
people who are really looking for
trouble would push.
So,
and,
and just a cursory glance at 20th
century history should teach anyone who
wants to know exactly how,
how unacceptable that is with regards to
your first,
okay,
there's the safe space issue,
but you also said something right at the
beginning,
you,
you announced your sexual preference at
the beginning and I understand exactly
why you did that,
but I have a comment about that and this
is something for people in the audience
to think about.
I've received at least 25 letters from
transsexual people and that's quite a
few because there aren't that many
transsexual people,
right?
So,
so they're rare.
They're very rare and every single one
of them.
But one was supportive and the one that
wasn't supportive was mildly critical
and they said exactly the same thing
that you said.
Rough.
Roughly speaking is that.
And so what we.
One of the things we want to remember is
that just because some some noisy
activists stand up and say,
because I'm a member of this group,
or even worse because I say I'm a member
of this group,
I am therefore an advocate for that
group's interests is we should just
dispense with that,
um,
with that self identification as a
worthy representative instantaneously
because it's predicated on the idea that
one dimension of a person's identity is
sufficiently what would you say,
broad and all encompassing so that you
can infer their political stance,
for example,
which you can't.
And so the,
the Trans people that have written me,
they all say the same thing.
A,
those people do not speak for me.
B,
we're not all the same.
See,
most of us think that the enforced
pronoun issue is doing nothing but
drawing negative attention to us.
D,
most of us just want to be referred to
by the other Pronoun.
That's the whole point.
So thank you.
So
this has been very,
very reassuring to me because one of the
things I presume right from the onset
was that there was no evidence
whatsoever that this nonsensical,
logical legislation and the postmodern
idiocy behind it is in fact demanded by
this community or that it will in any
way be in anyone's best interest.
No,
I don't buy it.
I think it's rotten,
right to the core.
So then the safe,
safe space issue.
It's like if you need a safe space,
see a therapist.
Really,
really university university is not a
safe space.
If University has done right,
it is a radically space.
If you want to go somewhere and get
yourself taken apart intellectually and
then hopefully put back together,
then you go to university.
Everything you believe should be
challenged in every possible way,
but not in a destructive sense.
Right?
Like when you're renovating a house,
you don't just burn it to the ground and
walk away,
but that's what the postmodernists due
to adolescence,
by the way,
you dismantle it in consultation with
its occupant,
attempting to build something even more
beautiful and functional on the.
On the foundation.
It's not a safe space,
you know,
in my classes,
and I tell my students this right at the
beginning,
I'm trying to get them to understand why
they are Nazis,
right?
There isn't anything more unsafe than
that.
And all of them,
virtually all of them,
right back to me afterwards and say that
this was the most worthwhile class I've
ever had in my life and it changed my
life.
It's like,
well,
I'm teaching you the worst possible
thing about yourself and your response
is,
oh,
that was so useful and I'm way better
than I was.
You know,
it's,
it's.
But it's in keeping with the idea that
you need to be exposed to things that
you fear and hate because that's where
salvation lies,
roughly speaking.
So yes,
uh,
you mentioned how humanity
and also how the good we need to attain
is essentially achieved through inactive
faith.
We're just speaking the truth the best
we can.
And what I've been thinking about is how
can we have competence in existence and
the good of the logos?
Is there anything to ground our
competencies?
That's a great question.
So what is there anything to ground our
confidence in the logos?
Yeah,
sure.
Two things.
One,
the testimony of the ages to practical
experience.
Try It,
try it.
You know,
and what you,
you start by while doing what I
suggested earlier,
which is fixing the things around you
that you can fix because that's like the
embodied manifestation of the logos.
That's by the way why Christ was a
carpenter,
are continually speaking,
right?
Because he fixed things.
So and you know,
if you're a bad carpenter,
the things you fix fall apart.
So there's truth in being a carpenter,
but then the next thing is you probably
can't speak the truth because no one
can,
but you cannot say things you know to be
lies and that's a really good place to
start.
And all you know,
you can learn to pay attention to that
very rapidly.
You kind of know already,
but you,
it's a consultation with your embodied
being.
When you say something,
you know to be false,
you won't be able to stand up straight.
You'll get week,
you'll feel a physical d division take
place inside you.
It's a shame because what you're not,
you're failing to bear the burden of
your existence and you're revealing that
to yourself by your use of deceit.
Stop saying things you know to be false
and then watch what happens and this is
the existential element of it.
It can't be proved as far as I can tell,
the same way that you would prove a
scientific hypothesis.
It can only be proved in the confines of
your life and you actually have to
sacrifice your life to the logos in
order to find out because the only way
you'll test it is by acting it out and
see what happens.
You don't get to do it twice.
So.
But I think the consequences will reveal
themselves relatively quickly.
My experience has been that because I'm
always working with my clients,
I say clinical clients 20 hours a week
roughly speaking,
and we're always working on stating
things more clearly,
trying to make things better,
you know,
and,
and it almost inevitably at least makes
the horrible things bearable,
which is a lot better,
you know?
And,
and sometimes makes mediocre things way
better as people's lives expand.
And they get more confident and,
and,
and straightened things out around them.
So,
so it's the testimony of the ages and
your willingness to test and
existentially in,
in the confines of your own life.
You'll find that there isn't anything
more interesting than you can do because
what it takes,
the predicted it takes the stultifying
predictability out of your life.
You never know what will happen if you
say something that's true,
it's a miracle.
Miracles will happen.
And that's a very interesting.
It's crazily interesting.
And so that's good.
Crazily interesting.
You've got that to set to say that you
got that to set against tragedy and so
well,
so you can try it.